مرحبًا بكم في Metaversity ،
مرحبًا بكم في كلية مورهاوس في أتلانتا
جورجيا ، أنا الدكتورة ميسينا موريس ، الدكتورة
ميسينا موريس ، هي مديرة ميتافرتيتي
وأستاذ مساعد للتعليم في
كلية مورهاوس ، أنا في الواقع
أول مدير استعارة موجود في
جميع أنحاء العالم وكلية مورهاوس
هي أول metaversity  لقد
تحركنا بكامل قوتنا من ثلاثة
فصول في الأصل إلى الآن أكثر من 13
دورة في الفصل الدراسي ،
بدأ الكيميائي الجزيئي الحيوي موريس التدريس لأول مرة في metaverse في
عام 2021 لمحاولة الحفاظ على مشاركة الطلاب
أثناء انتشار الوباء ،
وهي
مساحات تعلم تفاعلية افتراضية تستند إلى واقع أو
البيئات المتخيلة لإنشاء
نماذج ثنائية رقمية للحرم الجامعي والمصممين يستخدمون
مئات الصور والبيانات الجغرافية
لبناء نفس البيئة في الواقع الافتراضي
يمكن للمدرسين تخصيص فصولهم الدراسية
بميزات إضافية مثل النماذج ثلاثية الأبعاد أو
المواقع الخيالية
عمل موريسون مورهاوس مع
مطوري الواقع الافتراضي التعليمي
Victory XR  في
حرم جامعي رقمي مزدوج مخصص ، هذا هو النادي الرئيسي حيث
تخرجنا ،
كانت الخطة الرقمية مهمة حقًا
للعمل الذي كنا نقوم به ببساطة
لأننا في كثير من الأوقات نقدم
برامج أو هذه التطبيقات حيث
لا يرى الشباب السود  أنفسهم
ينعكسون في تلك المساحة وامتلاك
التوأم الرقمي بالنسبة لنا يعني أنهم يأخذون
المزيد من الملكية والاستقلالية عن التواجد
في هذا الفضاء وما يريدون أن
يبدو عليه
عندما رأيت لأول مرة الميتافيرسيتي
كان انطباعي الأول يا إلهي كان
سرياليًا للغاية  لقد كان تعلم الواقع العالمي
مدهشًا للأشياء التي
أقرأها على الصفحة التي يمكنني رؤيتها
ولمسها حقًا في الواقع الافتراضي ، لذا
فهو
يربط النقاط بالنسبة لي كما ترى ، هذه
نسخة رقمية طبق الأصل من
مختبر الكيمياء الحقيقي لدينا أشياء رائعة حقًا  أريد
أن أريكم الآن
يقول مور إن الممارسة في المختبر الافتراضي
يمكن أن تساعد الطلاب على الأداء بشكل أفضل في
البيئات المادية التي لدينا فيها دش
يتم تدريس دروس الواقع الافتراضي في
الفصل الدراسي وعن بُعد ، ولكن في كلتا الحالتين ،
يقول مور إن التواجد في الفضاء الافتراضي
يساعد الطلاب على الاستمرار في التركيز  لقد رأيت
الطلاب يكتسبون إتقان المفاهيم بشكل
أسرع بكثير مما لديهم في مساحة الفصل الدراسي
حيث قد ينطلق الهاتف ،
لذا من الجيد حقًا
الاستفادة من الوقت بشكل فعال.
Victory XR بتمويل من meta لـ
Morris لقد كان حلمًا تحقق ، فقد
أعاد السعادة في نظام التعليم
وزاد إنجازات طلاب جامعة كاليفورنيا بنسبة
11.9 بالمائة ، مما يجعلك تعيد التفكير في ما
كانت عليه مناهجك الأخرى في
الماضي ولماذا انتظرنا طويلاً  افعل
شيئًا من هذا الخير التحويلي